this sounds like the most predictable
show if you just sit in the chair you I
sit in the chair you die not like the
chair has spikes but the chair does have
spikes but that's not what Cosby
[Music]
I feel like I live in a world where I'm
constantly inundated at like Game of
Thrones content and if none of that has
made me watch Game of Thrones good luck
I'm gonna omit all the unnecessary parts
and give just like a very brief overview
of a conversation exactly so it's like
musical chairs but with a lot more
beheadings and a little bit more incest
first thing you need to know is
everybody in the show [ __ ] each other
and everybody in the show kills each
other too much incest created a very Mad
King he did some very bad things some
people came in to take his throne today
so baby had a man named Ed stark who
says a lot of other bad things in
emotion while all of this is happening
there's this one lady with dragons it's
just kind of like slowly coming this way
the whole time towards so just coming
towards you right so Jaime and Cersei
over here they're brother and sister
okay and they have had incestuous
children together who are heir to the
throne basically incest it's caused some
problems but it will also be the
solution like this keeps happening like
you wear this and then stabbed to death
and then another person and then killed
not necessarily stabbed like some people
jump out of windows but we don't have
props for that how do I get through how
many people died okay basically there
will be no kings by the time the show is
over wasn't well this is Jon Snow he's
not really a start he's a bastard Ernie
got Arya she doesn't even have a face
anymore she's just going around stealing
people's faces like she has a face so
much okay
the to a dragon's coming towards you and
also iZombie x' yeah these are the eye
surgeries they're like these mythical
gross creatures that can only be killed
by dragonglass
Danny's currently sitting on a nice pile
of dragonglass so Jon Snow and Danny
might meet and maybe they'll [ __ ] but
they're actually cousins they're
definitely gonna there's a queen sitting
on the throne and she's kind of crazy
but she's amazing she's incredible I
love her this Queen named Danny curtain
she is destined to be with her cousin
Jon Snow that's it I feel like I know a
little bit more about Game of Thrones
most people talked about incest for a
long time the show to me seems really
like masculine and gory and like murder
incest and like knowing that that's not
all the show is makes me want to watch
it more first sure this show has a lot
of incest and I don't know why people
are trying to sell me on that like as if
it's a reason to watch something I'm
like okay what else